>> Tucker: IF YOU'VE EVER
WATCH CHRIS CUOMO ON CNN, YOU
WONDER HOW THIS GUY GOT A TV
SHOW.
HE HAS GOOD ABDOMINAL MUSCLES,
GOOD FOR HIM, BUT HE CAN'T SPEAK
ENGLISH.
JUST PURE GIBBERISH.
LIKE PIG LATIN, DOGS BARKING.
KIND OF REMARKABLE.
IS THIS GUY EDUCATED IN THE
UNITED STATES BOOKS MAKE LET'S
CHECK.
WAIT A SECOND.
THE ENTRY SAYS CHRIS FOREMAN
WENT TO YALE UNIVERSITY IN
CONNECTICUT.
YALE HAS FAMOUSLY HIGH ADMISSION
STANDARDS FOR YOUR KIDS COULDN'T
GET INTO YALE.
NO CHANCE FOR THEY'D HAVE TO BE
INCREDIBLY SMART, GENIUSES,
REALLY.
IS CHRIS CUOMO A SECRET GENIUS?
DOES HE HAVE SOME AMAZING TALENT
THAT'S INVISIBLE ON TELEVISION?
MAYBE HE SPEAKS URDU, A DEEP
GROUNDING IN PART OF THE
PHYSICS.
MAYBE HE CAN CALCULATE PI TO THE
FINAL DIGIT.
TURNS OUT HE HAS A MORE
IMPRESSIVE QUALIFICATION.
HIS FATHER WAS THE GOVERNOR OF
NEW YORK.
IF YOU WANT TO GET INTO A TOP
AMERICAN COLLEGE, IT'S BEST TO
HAVE A PARENT WHO IS A
WELL-KNOWN DEMOCRATIC
POLITICIAN.
THAT'S THE MOST EFFECTIVE
QUALIFICATION OF ALL.
DON'T TAKE OUR WORD FOR IT.
TAKE DANTE de BLASIO, THE SON
OF BILL de BLASIO, THE
INCOMPETENT MAYOR OF
NEW YORK CITY.
LIKE CHRIS CUOMO, HE SOMEHOW GOT
NTL.
ONCE THERE, DANTE de BLASIO
FOUND HIMSELF SURROUNDED BY
PEOPLE JUST LIKE HIMSELF, THE
THOROUGHLY AVERAGE CHILDREN OF
OTHER PROMINENT LIBERALS.
ACCORDING TO PRESS REPORTS, THAT
WOULD INCLUDE THE OFFSPRING OF
AT LEAST THREE DEMOCRATS
CURRENTLY SERVING IN THE U.S.
SENATE.
MICHAEL BENNET, AMY KLOBUCHAR,
AND SHELDON WHITEHOUSE.
ALL OF THEM SEND KIDS TO YALE.
DID YOU?
NO.
BUT THEY DID.
THEIR COLLEAGUE RICHARD
BLUMENTHAL IS A STUNNING NUMBER
OF SENATE DEMOCRATS WHO HAVE
SENT CHILDREN TO HARVARD
UNIVERSITY.
SENATOR BOB MENDEZ IS A HARVARD
PARENT, SO IT'S IN IS SENATE
MINORITY LEADER CHUCK SCHUMER.
SCHUMER SAID
TO MAKE SENSE BOTH OF HIS KIDS
TO HARVARD FOR BARACK OBAMA SENT
ONE OF HIS, SO DID FORMER
NEW YORK GOVERNOR ELIOT SPITZER.
THE RECORD GOES TO FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT AL GORE.
AL GORE'S AN FOUR -- IMAGINE
THAT, FOUR KIDS IN A ROW TO
HARVARD.
IT'S ABOUT AS LIKELY ABOUT
GETTING HIT BY LIGHTNING EVERY
SINGLE DAY OF THE YEAR, AND
SOMEHOW THE GORE FAMILY PULLED
IT OFF.
CONGRATULATIONS, GORE FAMILY.
ANDREW CUOMO, THE SITTING
GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK SENT ONE OF
HIS KIDS TO HARVARD, BUT SENT
SOME TO BROWN.
THAT'S ANOTHER IVY LEAGUE
UNIVERSITY THAT YOUR KIDS CAN
NEVER GET TO.
HIGHLY SELECTIVE, APPARENTLY FOR
THE KIDS OF NONPOLITICIANS.
NONE BEAT STANFORD YOU CAN NEVER
MEET A SINGLE PERSON WHO WENT TO
STANFORD.
IT'S THAT RAREFIED.
YET HERE IS THE AMAZING PART.
HILLARY CLINTON'S DAUGHTER READS
RIGHT IN.
HOW DID CHELSEA DO THAT?
WAS IT HER FORMIDABLE
BRAINPOWER?
YOU CAN CHECK OUT HER FOOD OR
FEED AND JUDGE FOR YOURSELF.
THERE IS A CHANCE THAT CHELSEA
IS INTENTIONALLY MISLEADING US.
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT HER
IF THAT'S THE CASE, CHELSEA
CLINTON IS UTTERLY BRILLIANT.
SHE'S THE JONATHAN SWIFT OF OUR
TIME.
BUT IT'S ALSO POSSIBLE THAT
CHELSEA ISN'T JOKING AT ALL.
IT'S POSSIBLE.
IT'S EVEN PROBABLE THAT SHE IS
EVERY BIT AS DULL AND SELF
SERIOUS AS SHE APPEARS TO BE.
IN THAT CASE, NOT ONLY IS
CHELSEA CLINTON PROFILED LISA
BRILLIANT, YOU HAVE TO WONDER
HOW SHE HOLDS A JOB.
HOW DOES SOMEONE LIKE THAT GET
INTO STANFORD?
SOME OF THE KIDS AT GEORGETOWN
UNIVERSITY IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
GEORGETOWN'S ALUMNI MAGAZINE
AVAILABLE ONLINE, SO THE NEXT
TIME YOU HAVE A SECOND FOR YOU,
TAKE A LOOK THAT YOU'LL
RECOGNIZE MANY OF THE NAMES
INSIDE.
BIDEN, PELOSI, KENNEDY.
THESE ARE THE CHILDREN OF FAMOUS
DEMOCRATIC POLITICIANS.
ARE THEY IMPRESSIVE, HARDWORKING
KIDS WHO DESERVE TO BE AT ONE OF
THE COUNTRIES MOST PRESTIGIOUS
UNIVERSITIES?
MAY BE.
MAYBE SOME OF THEM.
MAYBE NOT.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
IT'S IRRELEVANT.
THEY ARE THE OFFSPRING OF
PROMINENT DEMOCRATS.
THAT'S THE POINT.
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE AT THE
GEORGETOWN FEAR AND HOW DOES
THIS HAPPEN?
IT HAPPENS BECAUSE OUR
MERITOCRACY IS A SHAM.
IT'S FAKE.
THEY TELL YOU THAT ONLY THE MOST
ACCOMPLISHED STUDENTS GET INTO
THESE SCHOOLS, BUT THEY ARE
LYING.
THEIR FRIENDS' KIDS GET FIRST
DIBS, KIDS WHOSE FAMILIES CAN
HELP THEM DOWN THE ROAD.
THE CHILDREN OF SOME PATHETIC
POLITICIANS ARE AN OBVIOUS
PRIORITY FOR ADMISSIONS
OFFICERS.
THESE ARE THE SAME POLITICIANS
WHO FUNNELED BILLIONS OF TAX
DOLLARS TO COLLEGE UNIVERSITIES
EVERY YEAR.
LETTING A SENATOR'S KID EVERY
YEAR IN IS QUICK QUOTE PRO,
UNREGULATED LOBBYING.
REMEMBER THE VARSITY BLUES WERE
A GROUP OF SOCCER MOMS TRIED TO
GAIN IN THE ADMISSIONS SYSTEM?
THIS IS FARM WORK CORRUPT.
HOW MANY CHRIS CUOMOS GET IN
EVERY YEAR?
JUST LIKE HIGHER EDUCATION, IT'S
A PICTURE PRESTIGIOUS SCHOOLS
PRETEND THEY ONLY ADMIT THE ONLY
QUALIFIED APPLICANTS BECAUSE
NOBODY CAN PROVE OTHERWISE.
THE REAL ADMISSIONS NUMBERS ARE
SECRET, HIDDEN FROM PUBLIC VIEW.
EVEN THOUGH WE PAY FOR THOSE
SCHOOLS BECAUSE ALL OF THEM TAKE
MASSIVE AMOUNTS IN TAX DOLLARS.
ELITE COLLEGES ARE LIKE PUBLIC
COMPANIES THAT LIE ABOUT THEIR
BALANCE SHEETS.
THEY ARE COOKING THE BOOKS TO
DEFRAUD SHAREHOLDERS.
IN THIS CASE, THE SHAREHOLDERS
ARE THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
A HANDFUL OF ELITE SCHOOLS FROM
THE GATEWAY TO SUCCESS IN
AMERICA.
IF YOU GO TO HARVARD, YOU ARE
ALL BUT GUARANTEED TO MAKE MONEY
OVER THE COURSE OF YOUR LIFE
THAN SOMEONE WHO DIDN'T GO TO
HARVARD.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
AND SO WHEN YOU RIG THE
ADMISSION SYSTEM, WHAT YOU ARE
REALLY RIGGING IS AMERICAN
SOCIETY.
YOU ARE CREATING AN IMPENETRABLE
CLASS SYSTEM FOR YOUR OWN
BENEFIT.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THEY ARE
DOING.
YOU OFTEN HEAR PROGRESSIVES SAY
THAT THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT
INCOME INEQUALITY.
THEY DON'T MEAN IT.
AT ALL.
HOW DO YOU KNOW THEY DON'T MEAN
IT?
IF THE LEFT REALLY CLEARED ABOUT
THE STRATIFICATION OF AMERICAN
SOCIETY, THEY WOULD MAKE COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS TRANSPARENT.
THEY FORCED STANFORD TO OPEN THE
BOOKS AND SHOW US HOW THEY ARE
ASSEMBLING THIS YEAR'S FRESHMAN
CLASS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO.
BUT DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS
HAVEN'T DONE THAT.
AND WANT TO DO THAT.
THEY SEEM STRANGELY INCURIOUS
ABOUT HOW THE PROCESS WORKS.
LIKE THEY DON'T WANT TO KNOW ALL
THE DETAILS.
IN FACT, THEY ALREADY KNOW